hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar when confidence and
consciousness collide neural and
computational approaches to
understanding how the brain creates
subjective experience I am Christina
Mahalo collaborates and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots believing scientific social
networking website and provider uber
children's in webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning to
learn more visit lab roots comm let's
get started you can post questions to
the speaker during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so just simply type them in the Q&A box
which will open when you click on the
green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window questions will be answered after
the presentation to enlarge the slide
window click on the screen icon in the
lower right right-hand corner of the
slide window if you experience any any
technical problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
button found at the top right of the
presentation window or record the
problem by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the screen
it is now my pleasure to present today's
speaker Megan Peters PhD postdoctoral
researcher University of California Los
Angeles
Megan Peters is a postdoctoral
researcher at the University of
California Los Angeles she received her
BA in cognitive science from Brown
University in 2006 and her PhD in
computational cognitive neuroscience
from UCLA in 2014 during her doctoral
training she received the National
Science Foundation graduate research
fellowship and the National Institutes
of Health Training fellowship Megan's
research uses computational models and
machine learning approaches to explore
the neural computation
underlying perception met a commission
in subjective awareness her research
uses a multidisciplinary approach to
gain insights from the human behavioral
and neuro science as well as non-human
primate and rodent models dr. Peters
will now begin her presentation ok thank
you very much to lab roots for hosting
this virtual conference and for inviting
me to share my research with you all
today as Christina just said my name is
Megan Peters I'm a postdoctoral
researcher at UCLA in the psychology
department and today I'm really excited
to tell you about some of the research
that I've been working on for about the
past two-and-a-half years on the
relationship between metacognition or
confidence judgments and consciousness
or subjective awareness itself okay so
for my entire scientific career I have
wanted to study consciousness I want to
ask how do our brains create this
subjective sense of the world around us
and what neural computations underlie
the subjective nature of our perceptions
and our metacognitive ability to reflect
on those perceptions and in my graduate
work during my PhD I studied perception
itself and I used computational models
and mathematical modeling to describe
the relationship between objective
reality and subjective experience
especially when they don't match as in
the case of illusions so a few years ago
when I finished up my graduate work I
felt I was in a great position to use
computational models to study subjective
consciousness so based on my ideal
observer modeling background I wanted to
show that visual masking breaks down
optimality by creating something that
looks like blind sight in normal
observers so the neurological condition
of blind sight occurs in some patients
who have damage to their primary visual
cortex
is the first cortical stop along the
visual processing stream and these
patients can do some visual tasks like
correctly orienting a letter to put it
through a mail slot that's vertical or
horizontal or telling you whether a line
on a computer screen is tilted left or
right but they report no visual
experience they say they can't see even
though they can do these tasks so from a
scientific perspective this disorder is
really fascinating because it decouples
the ability to see from the subjective
experience of seeing but this is really
hard to study of course because these
patients are very rare so some
researchers have tried to induce this
effect where you have task performance
but you have no subjective awareness
they've tried to induce this effect in
neurologically intact observers using
techniques such as visual masking so in
visual masking you make the stimulus
very dim and you mask it with other
images that are flashed very near it in
space and time and when you do this even
neurologically intact observers show
similar behavior they're able to do some
discrimination task but they report that
they can't see the stimulus at all that
they cannot introspect on their choices
and they have low confidence in them
okay and so for me this was really
exciting to study okay so there's this
problem though when I looked at most
paradigms that are used to study this
phenomenon most of the time when people
do this they use a paradigm that looks
like this they show people some mask
stimulus and they ask for a decision
about it and also ask for some sort of
confidence or visibility rating
afterwards so they assume that if
there's high signal you're going to say
you saw the thing and if there's no
signal you'll say you did not see it and
we'll call these the conscious and the
unconscious trials
respectively and so you demonstrate that
on those unconscious trials people can
do the task and then you've demonstrated
sub optimality but here's the problem
there's a third option which is that the
subjective signal is weak but it's still
there it's just not strong enough to
pass some sort of internal criterion or
threshold to prompt the person to say I
saw the thing so they say they didn't
see it even though they sort of did but
they can still do the task well that's
actually not very interesting is it
there is a signal there so of course
they can do the task they're just
reluctant to tell you they saw the
stimulus because the signal wasn't
strong enough to pass some sort of
internal criterion and so this is the
criterion problem and it's really a
problem indeed so depending on where
each observer puts their own internal
line for dividing samples into seen and
unseen reports you might get subjects
who see everything they never use the
bottom of the scale they never say I
didn't see it or I have low confidence
but importantly you might also get
subjects who see very little they put
that internal line too high so they're
really unwilling to use the top of the
scale and suddenly you think you've
found wine site in this normal observer
but all you've really found is someone
who's not willing to report that he saw
something and this is really a concern
for studies of consciousness because
when we see in an experiment that people
can do some tests but they report no
awareness that might not actually tell
us anything interesting at all so if we
go looking for brain areas or other
neural correlates that do this kind of
unconscious perception we don't even
know what we're actually looking at and
this problem is far from new people have
been reporting it for 50 years and it
still exists despite previous efforts to
solve this problem in the context of
studying unconscious perception in this
way so clearly if we want to figure out
how blindsight in decay
sub optimality and subjective or
introspective computations we're going
to have to fix this
so we have to design a criterion free
task in order to be able to really
conclude that this blindsight like
behavior with a mask stimulus is a true
case of sub optimal introspection so now
instead of asking people to rate their
confidence in a way that relies on that
internal criterion we go to our friends
signal detection theory and we use a two
interval forced-choice so in this type
of task you ask observers to make
judgments about two stimuli one after
the other and then to say which of the
judgments they feel more confident in so
you show a participant a stimulus and
you ask them to make a first decision
and then you show them a second similar
stimulus and you ask them to make a
second decision and then you say which
one will you bet that you got right
which one are you more confident in so
this completely removes any reliance on
any internal criterion so to use this
type of two interval force choice to
test for blind sight like suboptimal
introspection what we do is we actually
remove the target in one of these
intervals so the idea here is if you can
discriminate the target when it is there
but doing this discrimination task is
subjectively or introspectively
no different from discriminating nothing
at all like when the target isn't there
then what you'll do is you'll answer
50/50 when we asked you which decision
you feel more confident in so now you
can do the task but you're 50/50 on this
confident judgment betting on the target
present or the target absent interval so
we arranged each trial in our experiment
like this where we mask an oriented
gabor patch target so that's a
sinusoidal grading and it's there in the
Red Square and it's tilted to the left
or right of vertical and we mask it with
a forward and backward masking paradigm
so that we presented
sandwiched in time and very quick
succession with these other colorful
images and in a second interval we show
the exact same thing but the target now
is not there and we show people these
two intervals at varying contrast levels
for the target when it is there up to 13
levels and we ask them to bet on which
decision they will get right that is
which one they feel more confident in
than saying whether it was tilted to the
left or right from vertical and then
also to indicate the orientation of that
gabor patch for both left and right
tilted and with this paradigm we have a
really easy way of detecting that blind
sight like sub optimality so to do this
we plot the percent correct on the
orientation task when the target is
present on the x-axis and on the y-axis
we plot the percent of time that
participants say that the target present
interval is the one that they're more
confident in and we would expect sub
optimality of this blindsight type to
create a curve that looks something like
this so here where the curve is flat
right here you can do the orientation
discrimination task when the target is
present but doing this task is
introspectively
no different from doing the task based
on an invisible target so this would be
the suboptimal introspection that we're
looking for and once we find that then
we can go about using various bayesian
observers to figure out why and how
people are suboptimal
seems like a good plan but see there's
this pesky thing called data and data
get in the way when you have the very
best of intentions so we're looking for
this elbow type behavior where it's flat
and then it rises along as you get
better on the orientation percent
correct task but we saw no trace of this
elbow this suboptimal behavior we even
did a second experiment where we played
with feedback and the order of the
questions and the results look basically
identical and we did another experiment
using continuous flash suppression
which is a different kind of masking so
instead of forward backward masking now
we show being imaged to one eye the
target to one eye and then we show to
the other eye a lot of colorful images
flashed in very quick succession and we
found the same behavior and this work
was done by an excellent graduate
student in the lab by the name of JD
Knotts so it turns out excuse me that
when you build a Bayesian ideal observer
that does this orientation
discrimination task when the target is
there and then it bets on which of these
two intervals has a higher posterior
probability so that's the higher
probability of it being correct in the
orientation discrimination task when you
build an ideal observer to do this you
get essentially the same behavior so
this was pretty surprising to me I
really thought that I would be able to
see this suboptimal behavior by using
these techniques because that's what had
been reported in many studies in the
literature and not only that with this
very conservative to interval
forced-choice
parent paradigm people don't even show a
hint at sub optimality they are ideal
observers so this is a very hard thing
to reconcile with those blindsight like
studies that use visual masking that
have been reported previously but then I
thought well maybe visual masking this
forward backward masking or continuous
flash suppression maybe this is just not
the right way to go about getting this
behavior maybe we need to do something a
little bit stronger than just
manipulating the stimulus so since I
done some brain stimulation in the past
that seems like a logical next step to
try so in collaboration with Tony Rowe
at the Graduate Center of the City
University of New York we applied this
to interval forced-choice confidence
paradigm using transcranial magnetic
stimulation or TMS to visual cortex at
the back of your head so this time we
have all sorts of trials so people
didn't catch on to our trickery
so sometimes we put the target in both
intervals
times only in the TMS interval and
sometimes only in the no TMS interval
and of course we counterbalance all of
the order and so to get at those
something versus nothing trials like we
had in the previous experiment we can
look at these trials here
where we zap you when there is a target
and then we don't zap you when there is
not a target so this is akin to this
something versus nothing kind of
experiments we did previously and to
remind you it's this elbow behavior
where it's flat along the X acid axis
and then it rises as your orientation
percent correct grows this is the
behavior we're looking for but this is
what we found so you'd think that TMS to
visual cortex would reduce confidence in
your discrimination performance but
instead it increased it when we look at
those something versus nothing trials
people bet on that interval that
contains the target and it gets TMS more
often even when doing the task and due
to TMS they're they're totally guessing
at the orientation of the target so here
when D prime is zero that means they're
totally guessing so it's as if TMS
artificially inflated the sense of
confidence that people have in their
discriminations even as it really messed
up their ability to do the
discrimination to begin with so this
certainly isn't that suboptimal
blindsight like elbow behavior we were
looking for but it's also not ideal
observer behavior either so now we have
to figure out what's going on here so
here's our theory about why we got this
subjective inflation of confidence due
to TMS we can think about what the
perceptual system is doing as taking
samples from the environment and these
samples are corrupted by noise which is
environmental noise or internal
processing noise and this means that
they form a distribution of evidence
that you get through your eyes so if
you're asked to determine if something
on a computer screen
has a left tilt or right tilt the two
relevant distributions would be these
left and right
so when the thing out there in the world
has a left tilt you will have some noise
associated with your sensory experiences
such that you will sample on a trial by
trial basis a distribution of evidence
and when the thing has a right tilt
you'll get other samples with other
noise and so now what we can do is we
can put a criterion line in the middle
and say that evidence that falls on one
side of the criterion indicates a left
tilt and samples that fall on the other
side of the criterion indicate a right
tilted thing out there in the world so
when you decide this thing has a right
tilt what you're saying is that the
evidence you got on this particular
trial probably came from this
distribution on the right here and we
can separate this evidence further into
categories like strong evidence or weak
evidence
so here the strong evidence is far away
from the decision criterion that
separates the left tilt from right tilt
and the weak evidence is much closer so
it might be mistaken for left tilt so
now that we've set up this signal
processing environment we can ask a very
important question about what happens
when we zap you with TMS so TMS is
likely going to cause a very substantial
increase in the noise in your samples
right it's going to make everything
noisier makes you worse worse at the
task so suddenly all of your samples are
noisier so when we draw the
distributions now they're going to be
fatter like this so now your ability to
tell whether something is tilted left or
right is not as good they're making more
mistakes so sometimes when a sample
comes from the right tilt distribution
now you say left because it fell on the
left side of the criterion and sometimes
when it comes from the left joke
distribution you mistakenly say right so
this all makes sense so now what does
this increase noise do to our confidence
judgments well there's two possibilities
the first possibility is that you the
observer have some way of measuring the
noise in your own system so the noise
went up and you know that it went up you
the observer and you the observer also
know that you're making more mistakes as
a result you know that the information
you're getting is less reliable because
it's noisier so what should this do to
your confidence judgments well they
should go down right you have less
confidence overall and you know you're
making more mistakes the second
possibility is kind of the opposite you
don't know that the noise went up
because you have no way of monitoring
the change in your system so in this
sense you would be metacognitively blind
to the increase in noise so now you're
making more mistakes but you don't know
that you're making more mistakes and not
only that if you knew the noise
increased you should also update what
counts as strong evidence you should
move this line here this criterion for
what counts as strong evidence up to
account for the increase in noise but
since you don't know the noise increased
you don't update where you put this line
and so you might say hey I actually have
more of this strong evidence this
evidence that fell in this strong
category so your confidence will
actually go up so this second option is
kind of counterintuitive but it turns
out that if you build a Bayesian
observer model that implements this type
of ignore the noise rule that doesn't
update what it counts as strong evidence
even when there is TMS noise that it can
explain this TMS result quite nicely so
here this observer is metacognitively
blind and you see that the model does a
very good job of capturing the data here
this Bayesian observer is
metacognitively aware it knew the noise
increased so it decreased its confidence
judgments as a result but this does not
match the human participants behavior on
this task
okay so now some of you are probably
saying to yourselves wait a minute when
the noise increased there was more of
this weak evidence here there's more of
this - and in fact there was more of it
even over on this side of the criterion
so everything should balance out in the
confidence judgments even if you know
even if you don't know sorry the noise
went up right well there might be a
second thing going on too that compounds
this effect based on some previous
psychophysics work it seems like what
happens is once you've decided say
something is right tilt when you go to
judge confidence all you care about is
how right tilted it looks so if we
categorize the evidence you're getting
as in congruent with your decision on
the left or congruent with your decision
on the right at the same time as you're
happily accepting all of this new strong
evidence in favor of your decision as
proof that you've made the right choice
you're actually ignoring any evidence
that is incongruent
with your decision this is the evidence
that might indicate you made a wrong
decision but you just ignore it so both
of these things are going on you don't
change what you count as strong evidence
so you think there is more strong
evidence and you ignore that stuff over
there that is incongruent with your
decision now that you've decided the
thing is right tilted any evidence that
it was left tilted is not relevant
anymore so now the evidence you do have
this decision congruent evidence here
overall has a higher mean your
confidence in your decision goes up even
as your ability to do the task goes down
so the next question is do we need to
externally modulate the brain in order
to see this kind of decision congruent
evidence influence or rule for computing
confidence in a decision it turns out
you don't even need to do brain
stimulation to see that this is how the
brain seems to compute confidence you
can do this with straight old
psychophysics basic behavioral tasks so
to test this theory
I designed a new study I'm using just
stimulus manipulation so here the basic
idea is that you create two conditions
that have matched performance but
different confidence levels so here we
have a large tilt for low and low
contrast condition and here we have a
small tilt more high contrast condition
and high contrast condition and the
tasks in both cases is to say whether
this gabor patch this sinusoidal grading
on the computer screen is tilted left or
right from vertical just as before but
in one case it's tilted 45 degrees and
in the other case it's only tilted five
degrees from vertical and what we'll do
is we will titrate the contrast levels
in these two conditions such that
performance on the left/right
discrimination task is matched its
equivalent across the two so according
to that decision congruent evidence
theory what will happen is that because
there will be more decision congruent
evidence in this condition the high
contrast small tilt condition we should
also see higher confidence in this case
even though performance is mashed across
the two conditions so when we do the two
interval forced-choice tasks with these
two conditions and we plot our results
the same way as before not only do we
not see that elbow that we were looking
for originally but now we see that
people are indeed more willing to bet
that they got the discrimination
decision correct for the small tilt high
contrast interval then the large tilt
low contrast interval even though again
their performance is the same across the
two so the confidence judgment tags
along with the amount of evidence you
have favoring the decision that you made
which we manipulated here with the
contrast so it seems that we've got some
really intriguing evidence that once
you've made a decision
about the identity of something you see
out there in the world like this cat if
you have to judge your confidence about
whether you are right all you care about
is how much it look
like the thing that you decided it was a
cat once you've decided it's a cat
you really don't care how much it might
also slightly resemble the dog or a fish
or a bird in some other small way you
ignore all that other evidence that's in
congruent with your decision and just
report how cat like this thing looks so
this is the theory and there's some
other evidence that this might be
happening too we see self-consistency
effects throughout the literature we see
this font-size effect and we see even
hints of this computation in higher
cognitive computations such as
confirmation bias or the
representativeness heuristic okay so if
we think that this is what's actually
happening in the brain we need to test
this theory with multiple methods
because we are good scientists okay so
to look for neural evidence of this
theory we capitalized on a rare
opportunity in human neuroscience to
directly record signals from the surface
of the brain using electric choreography
in epilepsy patients so these patients
are undergoing surgery for reasons other
than this research but we can use this
opportunity to record what their brains
are doing as they're doing some tasks so
we record signals from the surface of
the brain while the subjects do this
classic perceptual and decision-making
task so here we show a stimulus it's a
degraded noisy face or how stimulus and
we asked subjects to say on every trial
is this thing that we flash very briefly
a face or a house and how confident are
you in your in your judgments so we then
use a wavelet transform to get these
electrode signals into the time
frequency domain and we see that the
relevant signal is really focused in
this high gamma range between about 80
to 120 Hertz and this is consistent with
many previous reports of the task
relevance of this frequency range so
this is where we focus our analysis we
take these time frequency signals and we
assign the power in the high gamma
frequency bands as features to pass to a
cross
they did linear support vector machine
classifiers so this is machine learning
now to decode to behavioral factors on a
trial by trial basis so we trained one
classifier one machine learning
classifier to decode what decision each
participant made on every trial the face
or a house when we train a second
classifier to decode whether the
participant indicated high or low
confidence on a trial by trial basis and
we plot the decoding accuracy as a
function of time after stimulus on set
and you can see that both behavioral
factors can be decoded well above chance
beginning about 200 to 400 milliseconds
after the onset of the stimulus so the
information is there in the brain
despite admitted limitations of acog
spatial coverage and other factors and
we can see this face evidence and this
house evidence there in the brain on a
trial by trial basis and we can see that
it varies independently so some trials
have more both face and house evidence
and some have less face and house
evidence and the balance of the face and
the house evidence changes on every
trial so next now that we can get this
face and evidence and house evidence out
of the brain using our support vector
machine classifiers now we can ask how
does this evidence get used to make
confidence judgments can we find support
for the hypothesis that people are
actually ignoring that decision in
congruent evidence when they judge
confidence so to answer this question we
take the trial by trial face evidence
and house evidence it varies
independently and we see what happens if
we try to predict whether the person
said face or house and low or high
confidence on every trial using two
possible rules one rule that does not
discard the decision in congruent
evidence and the other that does so
let's use these rules with an example
trial to see how they work on this first
trial you said face there was more face
evidence than house evidence and you'd
get it correct and the first rule that
we
examine is what we call the balance of
evidence or the difference between the
decision congruent and the decision in
congruent evidence so you're using both
so you chose face on this trial
so this balance of evidence is going to
be how much face evidence you had - how
much house evidence you had pretty
straightforward we're also going to try
a second rule for predicting our
subjects behavior which is the magnitude
of the decision congruent evidence alone
regardless of the decision in congruent
evidence as if the observer ignores that
incongruent evidence so on this trial
you chose face and you have some level
of face evidence so we'll see whether
that by itself without taking into
account the house evidence is also
predictive of your behavior and we'll
check how well these two rules are able
to predict our subjects decisions about
face versus house on every trial and
also how well they're able to predict
their confidence judgments and so this
is called a choice probability analysis
and what we see now is that we're much
better able to predict our subjects face
versus house decisions the decisions if
we take the balance of face and house
evidence together rather than just
looking at one so now we're looking at
the left side of the graph here and you
can see that the balance of evidence
rule really does much better at
predicting whether someone says face or
house on every trial then if you just
look at the evidence that is congruent
with their decision but this pattern is
very different for the confidence
judgments so we didn't actually gain
anything at all by taking the evidence
favoring the decision The Observer did
not make into account it's as if the
amount of that decision in congruent
evidence is totally irrelevant for the
confidence judgments like they're
ignoring it altogether
just like we saw in the psychophysics
and TMS results earlier so now that
we've seen some evidence that this
strategy might be what the brain is
doing and calculating confidence we
should probably see if it's even
biologically plausible
for a brain to do this at all so to see
what I mean
let's build a little model so here we
have units that each accumulate evidence
for a particular stimulus category these
kinds of units here essentially add up
the evidence for one type of stimulus
over time and these are like neurons and
areas such as Li P or Fe F or superior
colliculus
so in our toy example this unit on the
on the Left sorry likes vertical things
and this unit on the right likes
horizontal things and this mini network
is set up with a strong degree of
lateral inhibition between these two
units that have opposing tuning
preferences such that the more one guy
fires the more he inhibits or suppresses
the other guy and this strong lateral
inhibition is actually a really great
thing for neurons to do because it helps
the network not be susceptible to random
fluctuations that don't have anything to
do with the stimulus that's out there in
the world it's really able to average
out the noise very well and importantly
when we have strong lateral inhibition
like this we get out of this network the
balance of the evidence between the
evidence for vertical and the evidence
for horizontal so this is akin to the
posterior probability in a Bayesian
sense it takes into account both the
decision congruent evidence for the
choice that you'll ultimately make and
the decision in congruent evidence for
the other possible choice by subtracting
off that decision incongruent evidence
from the overall estimate at every time
step so let's say I show this little toy
Network a stimulus but the blend between
a vertical and a horizontal stimulus and
I ask it to make a decision is this
stimulus more vertical or more
horizontal and the unit's start
accumulating evidence and the more the
vertical one fires the more he and hits
the other guy so the output of this
network is something like the difference
in firing rate for the vertical unit
versus the horizontal unit
and so at the time of the decision which
is here when it reaches a decision
boundary the difference in firing rates
for the vertical versus the horizontal
unit will look something like this
and if I show you a treasure of this
network a similar stimulus that has the
same balance of vertical nystagmus but I
turn up the overall contrast I'll get
the same accumulation of relative
evidence here and at the time of the
decision here I will get the same firing
rate ratio at the end so we'll get the
same discrimination performance out of
these two conditions as we showed
earlier with our psychophysics and as
other researchers have shown as well but
remember this balance of the decision
congruent subtracting off the decision
in congruent evidence this can't be the
only thing that's retained by the system
because we know that there are different
confidence judgments associated with
these two conditions this one the low
evidence condition will have lower
confidence than this one the high
evidence condition so somehow we have to
be able to keep track of the absolute
evidence for vertical and horizontal
without doing that subtraction so what
we'll do is we'll modify this perfectly
normalized network so now we can assign
how much the neurons inhibit each other
to be this parameter W such that when W
is big the units really inhibit each
other and we get this perfectly
normalized network which is like a drift
diffusion kind of network and when in in
contrast we have small lateral
inhibition we have a race model so we
can also store the absolute amount of
evidence that existed for each of these
choice alternatives so here this is the
balance of evidence and here the units
accumulate evidence independently and
don't really care what each other are
doing now most previous work has assumed
that one or the other of these types of
normalization or lateral inhibition is
occurring in the brain
and there's certainly evidence that each
model type describes behavior well under
different circumstances but I don't
think that we have to choose just one I
think that we can have the best of both
worlds
because the truth is that all different
levels of this lateral inhibition exist
in the brain some units are more
normalized or more laterally inhibited
and some are less and this is called
tuned normalization and it's now been
reported by several groups doing
recordings of rhesus macaque or monkey
cortex and just to put one more thing in
the backs of your brains as we go
forward I'd like you to think about what
these neuron types might be particularly
good for in the sense of tasks that an
organism has to solve in the real world
so perhaps because they're better at
averaging out the noise these diffusion
units are better at discrimination type
tasks fine grained discrimination but in
contrast the unnormalized units that
have a small lateral inhibition they're
less inhibited overall and so they're
better at detecting things out there in
the world due to less inhibition and
these tasks are both important for an
organism to be able to do so let's now
see how this tuned normalization might
be built into an actual network of
neurons so now we'll start with this
network that we had before and we can
assume that that lateral inhibition is
accomplished by inhibitory interneurons
so that's this neuron here and this
neuron here and we explicitly specify
the recurrent excitation and the leak
that these units have such that they
look a little bit more like biologically
plausible neurons and our next step now
is to create two populations of these
units a more inhibited or more
normalized set where the degree of
lateral inhibition is high and a less
normalized set where the degree of
lateral inhibition is low so now we can
do some cleanup because we can assume
that units that have the same tuning
preferences don't have separate pools of
inhibitory interneurons so this unit
and this unit like vertical things and
they excite the same inhibitory
interneuron that then inhibits the guys
that have opposing tuning preferences
and we can imagine that the equivalent
connections go on over here for those
that like horizontal and now we can
parameterize and we can say that how
each unit updates its firing rate
activity on a time step by time step
basis is a function of this scaled input
drive subtract off some leek add on some
recurrent excitation but then here we
want to subtract off the amount of
firing that opposing units have units
that have opposing tuning preferences
and we scale that subtraction by whether
a unit is more or less normalized
overall so that's nice now we have four
units instead of two this isn't much of
a network though and it doesn't really
explain how Tunes normalization relates
to decisions or confidence judgements
quite yet so to do that we should make
our network bigger we need more than
just four units so now we have our
inputs vertical vertical and horizontal
and now they're connected to a layer of
these accumulator units where we have a
lot of these units and each of these
accumulator units has the same recurrent
excitation and leak of our previous
little toy version and now we add
recurrent excitation among similarly
tuned units such that units that have
the same tuning preferences exciting
based on how similar their preferences
are and lateral inhibition based on the
same idea units that are opposing li
tuned and hibbett each other and units
that have the same tuning donating don't
inhibit each other and then what we'll
do is we'll scale this lateral
inhibition based on whether we're
assigning the unit to be more normalized
or less normalized so now we can finally
hypothesize about how normalization may
relate to decisions vs. confidence
judgments so we tried out some different
models and it turns out that the one
that does a great job of explaining some
surprising findings in the literature is
one that works like this
we're the more normalized or what we
called those discrimination units
contribute more to the decisions and the
less normalized or what we call the
detection units contribute more to the
confidence judgments and once you've
made a decision
say horizontal then confidence is read
out as the decision congruent units
activity based on how normalized they
are okay so the next big question is how
does this network do
can we actually predict behavior using
this neural network and it turns out
that we can it actually gets everything
right so it captures that you can have
matched performance but different
confidence that when you add noise with
TMS you'll get higher confidence rather
than lower confidence it captures that
confidence and reaction time are
inversely correlated which lots of
people have shown and it also captures
some counterintuitive effects that have
been reported in the literature like
when you do some very clever and bizarre
stimulus manipulations you can change
metacognitive sensitivity so that's the
correlation between confidence and
accuracy on every trial you can make
this go down even as people get better
at the task even as their accuracy is
going up and you can also introduce not
noise but volatility into the stimulus
and not change accuracy so accuracy
stays the same but confidence goes up
and this model predicts all of these
very strange behavioral reports so we've
now been working with Michele basses
group here at UCLA to try to identify
Tunes normalization in the superior
colliculus of rhesus macaques monkeys
using multi-channel electrodes and so
far we do see some evidence that Tunes
normalization does exist in this
oculomotor decision-making area and this
lends further credence to the hypothesis
that this neuronal property is directly
related to the perceptual and
decision-making apparatus so we're
currently working on critically
examining the evidence that we found
and relating this to normalization to
choice and confidence behavior as
produced by these movies so what this
really says to me is we have this
circuitry that's kind of specialized for
fine-grained discrimination on the one
hand and we're where you can average out
the noise and then on the other hand
you've got these these units that can
detect minut amounts of information out
there in the environment and both of
these abilities are really important for
an organism to have and it seems like it
is this detection half of the circuitry
that's primarily recruited when you ask
an observer to make introspective
computations like judging confidence in
a decision okay so really all this can
be summed up as you're doing some tasks
once you've made a choice to report your
confidence in that choice all you care
about is how much evidence there was
favoring your decision once that
decision is made any evidence that could
have supported an opposing
interpretation is tossed out it's no
longer relevant to subsequent
introspective evaluations and we've seen
this across a number of studies now from
our lab and other labs too and it seems
like it extends beyond perceptual
decisions even to fear detection and it
turns out that this strategy for
introspective confidence is not even
unique to humans so right now like I
said I'm doing some really exciting
follow-up work with Michele Basso and
non-human primates and I'm also working
with Alicia's Kyodo here at UCLA to do
this a similar type of task in rodents
and it turns out that even rats show
this same a behavioural effect so here
we've matched performance on these two
conditions but on the one that has
higher evidence the rats wait longer for
a reward showing that they are more
confident so the great thing about
working with animals other than humans
is that you can really capitalize on
exciting techniques that are unavailable
in human work so will human neuroscience
is great I think it's really important
to capitalize
these exciting technical advances that
are possible in animal research okay so
decision congruent confidence it seems
kind of silly when you think about it
that the brain is actually tossing out
information that you'd think would be
relevant to its decision and its
confidence judgments but yes this is in
fact what people monkeys and rats seem
to be doing and yes this does seem to be
what's happening in the brain to that
the brain has access to that decision in
incongruent information we can see it we
can use it to predict a face versus a
house decision but then when it comes to
confidence judgments the brain totally
ignores it we also saw that this
strategy however suboptimal it may seem
is actually biologically plausible and
it produces all of these kinds of funny
confidence behaviors so now I have to
take a step back and say ok I started
this whole talk by talking about
consciousness but then I tricked you and
I spent the whole time telling you about
confidence but really I think we can
learn a lot about consciousness from
studying confidence and here's why I
think the two are interred inextricably
intertwined what kind of conscious
perception do you have if you have zero
confidence what would it mean to say
that you actually see something but you
have no confidence not low confidence
but zero confidence in what you're
seeing think about it if your perception
is genuinely conscious it should always
come with at least some level of
confidence it doesn't make sense to see
something and have zero confidence in
what you're seeing so this seems to
imply that confidence is necessary for
awareness that whenever there is even a
little awareness confidence comes along
for the ride so I've argued that
confidence is necessary for
consciousness but is it sufficient for
example it's conceivable that you might
have confidence about
something that you've decided without
being conscious of the thing itself or
of your decision about it so you might
argue that in that first study I talked
about that very first study where you
have to discriminate two things and bet
on which one you're more likely to get
right that perhaps what people were
doing in this confidence betting task
was based on some sort of unconscious
hunch they didn't see the stimulus but
they just had a gut feeling that they
were going to get it right more often in
that target present interval so they bet
based on that gut feeling well when I
didn't show you though is that if we
change the question and we ask people to
simply indicate which target was more
visible regardless of whether they think
they got it right they show essentially
the same behavior there's no blind site
when you change the question either so
this means that when people are
confident in something even just a
little they are conscious of it even
just a little and vice versa so in
humans at least who have no neurological
deficits we have empirical evidence that
confidence is a sufficient indicator for
consciousness as well so the point is
that these two things confidence and
consciousness they're really very
connected and they're connected because
the circuitry underlying detection of an
object is what gets recruited for
metacognitive or introspective judgments
of certainty in that decision confidence
and consciousness are interconnected
because they rely on essentially the
same computational machinery and because
the introspective system is set up this
way you get these funny behaviors like
when something that looks a lot like
what you decided it is you're very
confident in your decision about its
identity because you discount any
aspects of it that might suggest it's
something else and this happens
especially when the reason it looks a
lot like what you decided it is is
because you've got a lot of noise in
your system like when we zapped you with
TMS and you have more noise than you
think you do
this can happen when we zap you with TMS
so we introduce a bunch of noise but it
could also happen that the perceptual
system underestimates the amount of
noise that it has for other reasons so
one example of this that I really like
is in the periphery of our vision so our
rods at the edge of our retinas are very
bad at detecting fine detail and they're
completely unable to detect color yet
what we subjectively experience in the
periphery is a whole lot more like this
picture on the left sorry on the right
than the picture on the left we don't
think we see only black and white and
fuzzy things in our visual periphery no
instead we see color we see fine detail
where we think we do we actually have an
inflated sense of confidence in the
color and the detail that we've
perceived and maybe the reason is that
the system has underestimated the noise
that occurs in the periphery of our
vision so others in the lab now are
investigating this type of subjective
inflation in the periphery so this
decision congruent evidence model really
does show how errors in the calculation
of confidence and over reliance on
decision congruent evidence that this
can really account for the nature of
subjective experience or awareness so
with that I'd like to thank all of my
collaborators without whom this work
would not have been possible and also
our funding sources and you all my
audience for your attention thank you
thank you dr. Peters for your
presentation in the Q&A box found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and dr. Peters will answer as many
questions as we have time for today so
the questions excellent dr. Peters when
you
when you decoded decisions and
confidence to the location of the
information change in the brain this is
a really good question is is how the
representations of decision and versus
confidence do they look the same even
though the calculations look like
they're different so I think the best
way to answer this question is to show
you some work that we did on trying to
get at what those representations look
like in the brain and where they are and
when they arise so here on the upper
left of the graph is what I showed
earlier in the presentation but what we
can do from this decoding of the
decisions and the confidence judgments
is we can actually parcel ate the
information so that you can assign to
every electrode that we record from
across all of our participants how much
each electrode at each spot in the brain
contributes to our ability to decode so
to the extent that we can actually
decode decisions or confidence judgments
which electrodes are the important ones
to being able to do that decoding so now
if we look at the the lower part of the
graph here panel B you can see these are
the little dots represent all of the
electrodes that we have recorded from
all of our subjects and you can see that
on the top row of panel B that the
decision information really does seem to
rely more on these occipital electrodes
here especially between 200 to 600
milliseconds after the stimulus onset
and the representation looks a little
bit different for the confidence
judgments there are fewer red dots
overall but there are some more red dots
that appear here more in like the
parietal and even frontal regions and so
to get at this distribution of
information in a slightly different way
the next thing that we did was we can
group these electrodes by whether they
belong to one of the
for neocortical loads so the the frontal
lobe the parietal lobe the occipital
lobe and the temporal lobe and then we
can plot the average contribution of
electrodes that are in that neocortical
lobe as a function of time after the
stimulus onset and so that's what's
plotted up here in panel C and so you
can see that when we split it up by the
neocortical lobe that for decisions it's
really the occipital electrodes that are
doing the heavy lifting and to a little
bit of extent it's the parietal
electrodes to our sorry the temporal
electrodes but those frontal and
parietal electrodes especially early in
the trial period are not actually doing
as much of the heavy lifting they do
tend to tend to be more important later
and this pattern is really quite
different for the confidence judgments
so you do see this little occipital
spike here but it's later than the
occipital spikes that you see for the
decisions and it's not as strong and
it's not a sustained and then we also
see then that despite the fact that
during decisions occipital electrodes
are really winning they're contributing
the most for most of the Paris stimulus
window that here it actually switches
for the confidence judgments such that
first it's the occipital electrodes and
then it's the temporal electrodes that
are doing the heavy lifting so this
shows us that even though we can decode
the representations to a similar extent
for both decisions and confidence
judgments that the nature of these
representations is really quite
different and one more piece of
information that I can show you that the
representations are really very
different from each other is here so now
that we know how much each electrode
contributes to decoding each behavioral
factor we can see which are the most
important electrodes for decoding
decision and confidence judgments and
then we can see where those most
important electrodes are and see where
they overlap and so to the extent that
you do have electrodes that
significantly contribute to both
decisions and confidence judgments
they're pretty much in the occipital
region maybe a little bit in the
temporal region but if you look at the
y-axis over here you can see that
there's really not a lot of feature
overlaps so the electrodes that are
important for decoding decisions are
really not the same as the electrodes
and the features that are important for
decoding confidence judgments so I hope
that answers your question
maybe people had a gut feeling or a
hunch but still didn't actually see the
target and that's what made them able to
[Music]
write so um this is this this question I
actually get a lot when I talk about
this study so part of it can be answered
by the similarity between the answers
that participants gave when we asked
them to report their confidence versus
when they reported just the visibility
of the target so you'd think that if
they're doing the confidence judgment on
the basis of some gut feeling or hunch
that maybe they wouldn't be depending on
the same thing when we asked them about
visibility that that instead hopefully
what they're reporting is the actual
visual experience or visual qualia of
those stimulates but I think this also
can really be answered by the way that
we define blind sites the way that we
define subjective experience in this
task so what we're asking with this task
is here if I go to this slide what we're
asking with this task is if you can do
this task above chance when the target
is actually there
but doing so is introspectively or
subjectively no different from doing the
task when the target is physically not
there then you will be at 5050 and so
having a gut feeling or hunch in essence
there is something that it is like to
use philosophical language something
that it's like to have that gut feeling
or hunch that is subjectively different
from doing the task based on nothing and
so in that way we would say that these
people are not actually metacognitively
blind they do have some introspective
ability to do the task on the basis of
that gut feeling your hunch even if it's
not visual in nature this is a great
question
so to answer this question I'll show you
the stimuli that we use so we actually
made use of we made use of some data
that had been collected previously that
we're not having to do with this study
but they turned out to be very useful so
in the type of task that we use the
monkey is fixating on the screen and
then so here and we've we record from
the neurons and the superior colliculus
using a multi-channel deep probe and so
previous to the task you actually map
what's called the response field of the
superior colliculus neurons so this is
the area in the visual field that these
neurons really like and then a dot
motion stimulus comes on and then you
measure the way that the neurons respond
to this dot motion stimulus and the
stimuli that we were interested in were
cases where you've got a bunch of dots
moving in one direction or you've got a
bunch of dots moving in two directions
and it
the same percentage of dots moving in
one direction or the other so we can
call this preferred 100% preferred or
50/50 preferred and non-preferred
stimulate and so then we can measure how
these neurons fire in response to these
stimuli and so in panel C you can see
that when it's a hundred percent what we
call the preferred stimulus so this
indicates that the monkey should make a
choice
towards that response field that the
neurons really like that they fire a lot
more than when it's 50-50 preferred and
non-preferred so for each neuron then we
can calculate how much they change their
firing rate when there's only preferred
stimuli on the screen versus when
there's both preferred and non-preferred
stimuli on the screen and every neuron
changes its firing rate a little bit
differently and from that difference we
calculate a modulation index so the
higher the modulation index the more
normalized the neuron is the more it's
inhibited by neuro by other neurons that
have opposing tuning preferences and the
smaller the normalization index the less
normalized the unit is the closer to
zero it is the less normal as it is and
when we calculate this modulation index
on the basis of disjoint trial subsets
so we just split the trials into even
and odd trials and we calculate this
modulation index separately we see a
really nice correlation between the even
and odd trials so this shows that Tunes
normalization really does exist in the
superior colliculus and this is actually
the first report of two normalization
outside the cortex in a subcortical
structure and it's the first report of
change normalization in these
accumulation type units so we're really
excited about that
okay well thank you so much
dr. Peeters for your time today we truly
do appreciate it and that is all the
time we have for questions do you have
any final comments that you would like
to close today we're really I'd just
like to thank everybody for your
attention for listening to me talk about
my research it's very exciting to be
here and thank you very much to lab
roots also for putting this together and
invited me to participate well it's been
our pleasure to have you present
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions we would like to
thank laberd's for today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through June 2017 labyrinths
will alert you via email when it is
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live events
i am christina mahalik with levers and
we'll see you here next time at laggards
comm good bye